what is up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 I'm so excited to talk about a
brand new VHS movie VHS 85 with David
brockner congratulations thank you I
love this one awesome great to hear I
really love the entire franchise this
installment in particular and I tweeted
this in my reaction it just feels like a
big celebration of the unique voices
that these movies tend to bring together
so kind of like a big broad question
because you've been a part of this
franchise since the very beginning you
directed on the first VHS movie you
directed here you also produced a number
of them so first a question from the
producing perspective what is something
about how you all produce these movies
that's evolved over the years in order
to maybe better support the individual
voices that come to these VHS films well
I mean the last three movies have come
to you know I mean the years Trilogy in
the in the VHS history would just be uh
94 99.85 uh we had the benefit of just
of of being able to see all the VHS
films that have been made what had
worked what hadn't worked quite as well
and uh I mean I think this is a place
where everybody can
run amok entertain themselves take a few
risks we try to encourage everyone to
get weird and do the kinds of things
they can't normally do
Mike Nelson was describing earlier it
was a place where he got to literally do
the things that he was told he could not
do in a different uh in a different
situation so uh if anything the
challenge is to not limit yourself and
uh you know they're the natural
constraints of found footage but
sometimes uh those constraints breed uh
like a special kind of creativity I did
have a question that kind of lined up
with that because I forget who said it
but someone in our production notes said
they were excited to be a part of this
movie because working on a short film
without any restrictions on the
necessary violence of the content was
very exciting so it sounds maybe I don't
know if you want to call anything out
but can you maybe give us an example of
a time when you ran into that problem on
a previous film but then also an example
of something you do here in 85 that you
know you were only able to accomplish
because there were no restrictions and
rules right right right uh uh yeah we
had a few things in Hellraiser we had to
slide by the ratings folks
um you know and then you you do the
thing where you cut uh you put things in
there that you know you're gonna lose
just so in case they ask you can go okay
fine we'll lose this one shot we did
something for you uh but no I think uh
as far as uh you know with VHS I can't
imagine I mean nobody's the the there's
no editorial oversight in anything that
anybody's creating if anything we're
just encouraging people to go further
but
um uh yeah and it's and it's also a
practical uh approach is strongly
encouraged so there's you know gallons
of blood getting thrown around the set
if anything the only frustration is that
the found footage is dark and murky
enough that you sometimes can't see on
camera how much blood there is in the
room uh so I the BTS photos are quite
revealing oh you should share some of
those but I will
darkened I feel like the amount of blood
was still quite quite clear and evident
in all of these shorts um I kind of want
to go back to the the beginning question
about how things evolve from a producing
standpoint but apply to your experience
as a director what is the biggest
difference between your experience
directing amateur night versus your
segment of uh of 85. well there was
about 11 years of filmmaking between the
two so which was part of the reason I I
wanted to come back and direct another
segment of VHS was just
um I kind of wanted to get back to that
um we all started making tiny indie
films we like to say held together by
duct tape and bubble gum and uh and then
you know doing Studio Movie is a bit
like steering an aircraft carrier so
wanting to not lose our footing in a
Terrain that had less friction where you
could really really experiment
um uh with something that I just wanted
to have that experience again but uh
yeah the difference I've changed uh what
you can get away with logistically has
changed a little bit
but I think overall it was kind of the
same same sandbox yeah just because I do
like I want to see you go make more big
Studio films again because I like all
your movies is there any particular part
of the VHS production process that maybe
they don't think they would benefit from
but you think that those bigger movies
would where maybe it is better to forego
the fancy tools and the big budgets in
exchange for how you do something here
that winds up being more effective right
right uh well I there's a lot of things
a lot of surprises in found footage I
mean found footage is harder than it
seems I think to a lot of folks on the
surface
um you're still filmmaking so
everything's designed you know you're
still lighting everything there's still
costuming that has to happen it's like
the performers are still having to
create a reality uh uh in front of the
camera the way you would on a normal
film but you just can't get caught doing
so so there has to be you have to strive
for a level of authenticity would like
to say you you have to make a movie but
not get caught making a movie but
inherent in that challenge are
opportunities to hang with a persistent
shot you know sometimes you're not
cutting the camera sometimes that
changes the metric of how you cover a
situation in some ways and so sometimes
you actually have more time
paradoxically to do things
um I mean there were takes in this that
we shot 15 16 times you know just to
kind of experiment and I in my
experience performers if there's a
reason to keep doing it can get very
very excited about the opportunity to
continue to play so um again I go back
to that that word friction it's there's
less friction uh in the creative process
at times and uh and that can allow you
to push it in ways you maybe can't do
when you have you know a giant machine
that you're trying to control or operate
are you able to tease the the scene that
maybe took something like 15 16 takes in
a spoiler-free manner oh yeah uh well in
the wrap around towards the end of it
there is uh something that culminates in
like a seven minute Warner and so you've
got running jumping screaming practical
effects there's blood hitting the wall
uh there's a lot happening all at once
and uh as a director looking at the
monitor I can't even comprehend
everything that's going down in that
moment of time between action and cut so
sometimes in the amount of time we could
take to stop and talk it all through we
just say let's go again and while the
energy is up what if it's faster harder
like let's let's break the moment and we
just push it even further but there's
yeah there's some dizzying running
around moments like not to be too
specific epic shot right there I'll come
back to it towards the end and I'll put
up a spoiler warning just so we could we
could talk about it in a little more
detail but I do want to go back to the
idea of you directing the wrap around
here first also because you are a
producer on some of these movies what
were the conversations like going into
99 I believe in terms of determining
that that movie did not have a need to
have a wrap around and then what were
the takeaways from that film that made
you decide that not only did this movie
need one but that you wanted to direct
it yourself right uh well the wrap
around something that's been kind of
it's been a moving Target since the
beginning it's been something that has
evolved uh quite a bit over the course
of the franchise and I think it was
after vhs2 uh the thought any consistent
mythology like Canon was abandoned on
the wraparound um it would have seemed
odd to try to go back and get it or
resurrect it necessarily and it really
became a place to experiment it's just
always changing when we got to 99 uh we
we decided to stop exploring the origin
of the tapes at all in a way and uh
someone had thrown out the idea of just
a mixtape and there was something
appropriately detached about an era
specific mixtape where things had been
taped over uh and you're only getting
fragments of what you're seeing
necessarily and so uh there was kind of
a wrap around element in VHS 99 in that
respect and
um uh it was the you know the the home
video the animation video that had been
seen and the by the time we got to 85 we
thought well let's just build upon that
let's do another mixtape let's do
another kind of incomplete taped over
piece of media and uh we had we Evan
Dixon uh who wrote the piece and myself
had come across
um some old Unsolved Mysteries like
Robert Stack uh Supercuts on YouTube and
just fell in a lot in love with the idea
of something slightly adjacent to found
footage where it is a curated edited
finished piece of media that gives you
you know total vibes from the era but
that you're only getting pieces of it
that it's a story that's like eerily
incomplete that was that was really the
draw and when you two decided on the
subject that you would roll with did you
immediately pinpoint Rory from the start
or did you ever toss around other other
ideas maybe inspired by Unsolved
Mysteries you guys came across it was
there were a lot of dead soldiers along
the way so we had a lot of different
things that we explored a lot of dead
ends we had the benefit also um just
process wise of uh and this was kind of
the plan from the beginning was to
finish all the other shorts first they
weren't finished finished but they were
you know uh uh near completion in post
so we had a kind of 30 000 foot view of
what the other shorts were and so part
of the inspiration that led us to the
ultimate conceit of it to Rory the
subject that's being studied in our
um our research doc was uh uh we were
trying to harmonize some of the ideas
and vibes from the other pieces and and
it just felt like something that could
run through the middle of it all can you
give us a specific example of something
that you changed in your own wraparound
segment based on what someone else did
in their segment so that that happened
not so much changed but I'll just say
again we were just pulling from
everything a bit there was
um you know in uh Gigi's piece and
Scott's piece you have uh you have
professional characters you have people
with a sense of Duty that has to be
performed which is different sometimes
than uh what you find in a horror film
which are a bunch of unsuspecting every
uh everybody's that are found in a
situation
um we drew from that we drew from the
body horror and Mike's piece the the
Sci-Fi and Natasha's piece
um uh uh the procedural elements and
Scots like all of that I think inspired
us to some degree or another we wanted
to wrap around to not leave any of the
shorts um on an island by themselves
that there would just be something in
the flavor of those that was kind of
running through the current middle of
the film it's very impressive how
uniquely their own every single short in
this film feels but also that it also
feels like a cohesive VHS movie too I
feel like that's one of the most
difficult things to do with any
Anthology and you guys Excel with that
here before I do my spoiler question I
do have to ask you about the future of
the VHS franchise and I mean this feels
this feels like there's only one right
answer to this question but is it safe
to assume that the the plan the hope is
to continue and do more they have to
keep going I mean there's no reason to
stop now
um we're not bored we're fascinated I
feel like the energy is there I mean
we'll hear from the audience but um uh
it would be my hope to see to see the
party ongoing are there any particular
years or even found footage formats that
are untapped in this franchise that you
would be eager to dig into in future VHS
films there are so many but I dare not
say that's fair I like that answer
because that means that they could
happen and I wouldn't want them to be
spoiled here I just want there to be
more of these movies especially because
of how you you Foster so many different
voices in this space it just seems like
no they have Limitless potential so
there's no reason to ever stop them
again definitely not yeah yep okay
before my spoiler question I did want to
ask you one fantastic fast question
because this is my first fantastic vest
and I'm so really I'm so so happy to be
here one of my favorite things about it
is just how many people are here
supporting each other which makes me
very happy and there's a lot of people
here supporting your film but you've
seen many other films so can you give me
an example of a time in a movie where
another filmmaker's work just like wowed
you to the point that you'll never
forget that moment and maybe it inspired
you as well there were several shorts in
the shorts with legs program that I
found particularly moving I'm afraid I
don't remember their names offhand but I
I have uh I certainly chased the
filmmakers down here at the festival and
expressed my gratitude for what they
made um and then and then weirdly uh we
caught a movie late night called uh door
that is resurrecting Japanese stalker
film that was for some reason just what
we needed to see that night and uh has
uh uh yeah just it brought us back to
something sparked some interest in a way
something really primitive and pure